well hello Harrison well hello Keisha I
loved this movie I cried it's beautiful
you seemed to have some sort of love
affair with dogs it's been in my year of
the dog
yeah I played a dog in pets too yeah and
when I did this movie and yeah I like
dogs I like dogs and that but this
movies the story of a dog on his being
ripped out of his domestic circumstances
in California and sent to the Canadian
Yukon to pull dog sleds for gold miners
during the gold rush at the turn of the
century and his relationships with
humans until he responds to he hears a
response to the call of the wild and
finds his destiny yes and the character
that I play is moved by his relationship
to buck - to have the strength to
confront his past and resolved to
address the issues that he ran away from
mm-hmm given that climate change is such
a huge issue in this country and I mean
worldwide are you hoping a film like
this will inspire young people to see
the beauty that's out there and want to
protect it I think young people are
aware of the threat of climate
and an hour are really assuming
positions of leadership and I'm
encouraged by that mm-hmm
this film is about the beauty of nature
the solace of nature the not about about
what human beings are doing the weight
of human population and the use of
fossil fuels are doing to the planet
right now but it but it reminds us of
the power and the majesty of of nature
yeah you said that you don't want to be
a leading man anymore or you're okay
with not being a leading man but we all
love you well I don't know any leading
man is it is a amorphous term yeah well
I I mean that I'm happy to play
character parts I enjoyed playing
character parts I've always wanted to be
a character actor and not necessarily
carry the burden of the leading man yeah
um what does Harrison like to do for fun
what is a day off like with Harrison
depends on where I am with the weather
is what I like to get outside that I
could and I like to play tennis I like
to ride my bike in the mountains
mountain biker or a road bike I just
like to get out and get some exercise
how fitting what is the update on
Indiana Jones five because we're very
excited about it well it's coming yeah
it is coming it's coming
we're having scheduling issues right now
but we're well on our way and I'm
looking looking forward to it awesome
thank you for your time Mary so much for
you